auf der Suche nach der perfekten
italienischen Pasta bin ich zu meinem
Freund Luigi nach Italien gefahren als
erstes wollten wir die perfekte Nudel
finden also haben wir halb Italien
bereist unzählige Produktionen besucht
und kiloweise Pasta gegessen aber
mindestens genauso wichtig die Soße
seitdem ihr meine Mama als ich klein war
frisches Pesto gemacht habe habe ich
panische Angst vor jedem Pesto dass man
im Supermarkt kaufen kann und wenn wir
ganz ehrlich sind nicht ein einzige
Supermarkt Pesto kommt an frisches
Kochen ran also haben wir scen getestet
viele so
und irgendwann habe ich sie gefunden
wenn ich jetzt deine Interesse gewgt
habe dann folg pastaapisier um nichts zu
verpassen